hey how's it going everybody i am dave
rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
for today june 10
20 21 subscribe
tap the notification bell share the
videos yada yada yada
uh we are mostly doing a q a today i got
uh a gajillion that was the technical
number a gajillion questions at
reubenreport.locals.com they're all over
the place
personal political cultural all that
good stuff
so we're going to mix it up with that i
should tell you guys
that i mentioned at the top of the show
yesterday that i had visited the dentist
yesterday morning i was having some
some tooth pain i think right after i
leave this i have an appointment at 1 30
i'm going to be getting
an emergency root canal today i am in a
lot of pain right now a lot of pressure
my head might explode which i think in
terms of views
and virality would be pretty good if my
head just absolutely exploded while on
camera that would be pretty good
but i'm in a degree of pain my guys said
dave
dave you work hard don't do the show
today relax
it hurts to talk to smile i said no
we must give the people what they want
and actually more than anything else i
really wanted to share
this video that we're going to start off
with so uh you know this whole week
the main story that i've been talking
about is this journalist from the new
york times mara gay
who's implied that i host a lot of white
supremacists on this show and
in addition to a bunch of other trash
that the new york times has said about
me well anyway she was
in long island which is where i'm from
and grew up and she saw american
flags on trucks and she thought that
that was somehow a sign of white
supremacy or trump's taking over again
or some other
horrible thing the sith are here it's a
lot of stuff uh
of course it's not that people post the
american flag because they're happy
that they live in america it's a pretty
spectacular place and
uh yeah it's a little it's a little iffy
at the moment but i think the great
american comeback is coming
uh well in any event uh yesterday uh i
believe it was game
six of the islanders bruins hockey game
at nassau
coliseum which is about 15 minutes away
from where i grew up
uh a singer-songwriter by the name of
nicole raviv was singing the national
anthem and basically the entire
freaking place just blew up singing with
her and i literally got
shivers tingle up the spine while i was
watching it little numbness in the mouth
but tingle up the spine and i want to
share that video with you guys
and just show you like caring about
america
and being proud of this country and
patriotic has nothing to do
with hatred or white supremacy or any of
the other nonsensical things that the
people of the new york times
uh like to believe before we get to all
of that
i want to talk to you guys about bambi
you know when running a business hr
issues can kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements
labor regulations the list goes on and
on and hr manager salaries aren't cheap
at an average of 70
000 bucks a year bambi spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e
was created specifically for your small
business you can get a dedicated hr
manager craft hr
policy and maintain compliance all for
just 99
a month with bambi you can transform hr
from your biggest liability to your
greatest strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time
chat from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day-to-day all for just 99
months month to month no hidden fees
cancel any time and if you're like me
then i bet you didn't start your
business because you want to spend all
of your time
on hr compliance let bambi help get your
free
hr audit today go to bambi.com ruben
right now to get that free
hr audit that's bambi.com ruben spelled
bam to the b-e-e dot com reuben and now
back to me i should tell you guys that
the reason i think i have to get this
freaking root canal is when i was about
11 years old
uh we we had a babysitter me and my
brother and the babysitter was a guy
who's probably like
i don't know 15 16 seemed old to me but
probably about 15 16
and we were pillow boxing basically just
wrapping up pillows
in in pillowcases and just beating the
crap out of each other and he whacked me
over the head
and my face hit like the formica around
the bed
cracked my two front teeth adult teeth
and basically pretty much destroyed them
so these bad boys over here these are
crowns these were
these were not cheap and now one of them
seems to be uh
seems to be going so it's a lot of
pressure i feel like something's not
right with my mouth right now i don't
know if you guys can see it but i feel
i feel an intense pressure anyway moving
along
from teeth and dental hygiene and by the
way brush twice a day everybody very
important brush twice a day sometimes i
brush three times a day sometimes
i always brush in the morning sometimes
a little bit after the show i've got my
guys here around three o'clock
people are working i always feel you
know why not a second brush and then of
course i like to brush at night all
right
uh so as i just said at the long
island's nassau coliseum and i grew up
in long island spent my formative years
in long island uh it was game six i
believe of the islanders bruins
hockey game i'm not a big hockey guy
although i'm kind of a hockey guy after
watching this
and nicole revive was singing the
national anthem and we're going to show
you the full thing because it's just
spectacular and you know the last couple
days i've been saying oh i feel like
there's sort of like an american rebirth
and like
we can turn the corner on this stuff and
we can start feeling good about america
and everything else
we'll just watch this and it makes me
proud to be a long islander and that's
the new york i know what you're about to
see right here
ladies and gentlemen presenting
tonight's colors is the new york state
university police
and now please join nicole revive as we
sing and together our national anthem
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
oh say does that star
[Music]
spangled
[Applause]
[Music]
i mean tell me that is not beautiful
tell me you didn't get
shivers up your spine i did again i've
watched it about 10 times right now
connor and michael both said the exact
same thing that's what it's all about
that has nothing to do with white
supremacy or racism or some of the other
delusional thoughts
that these new york times journalists
have okay those are people who love
their country long island is in some
ways sort of like the heart of new york
because as i said yesterday it's about
you know 45 minutes or so outside the
heart of long island sort of outside
of new york city you get this great
multi-cultural
multi-ethnic group of people blue collar
white collar you know second third
fourth generation americans it's just
that makes me so proud to be where i'm
from and be proud to be an american
and that's how we will beat this thing
that's how we will beat this thing it's
not through politicians coming in and
fixing it and it's not through
celebrities
uh making videos to tell us what's right
and wrong or any of that other stuff
it's that we
the people that's we the people and we
will fix this thing
and and how refreshing just to feel good
about america right for all of those
people
to be in that room together
spontaneously singing and you can see
sort of the way
that she you know she puts the mic down
she wants them to have that experience
actually it reminded me a little bit
just just a tiny tiny bit
of when i was on tour with jordan
peterson and at the beginning when i was
always warming up the crowd
i would want people i would make a point
of saying hey look around guys you're in
a room with thousands of other people
and they kind of think
something about the world that's kind of
close to the way you think about the
world and that's pretty awesome
that's how we will rebuild these bonds
so as the
as the country opens up like let's be
proud of who we are
let's fight for america and i'm so proud
to be from long island the place of
bagels and pizza
and the american flag or as they would
say in the new york times
you know real right-wing racist bigoted
homophobic
white supremacist stuff okay let's get
to a q a you guys submitted a ton of
questions
at reubenreport.lo i will plow through
as
many as i can and again if my head
explodes and there's just blood dripping
everywhere and just a
you know a carcass with a exploded head
i apologize
in advance okay here we go uh blake says
hey dave what do you think about
employers making vaccines
mandatory or penalizing people who
choose not to get the vaccine
i mean i would be completely against it
now look i suppose at some level
as an employer i guess i mean well first
off this would have to deal with like
hipaa laws and and states have different
laws related to medical privacy and all
sorts of things you know we do also have
uh amendments that defend our ability to
have
the right to privacy and that sort of
thing i know that's old school
that's old-school stuff i suppose at
some level
maybe depending on the type of business
it was
i guess you could kind of oh i don't
know about
forcing no i can't get behind that i
can't get him behind an employer
forcing anyone to do anything with their
body that just seems
fundamentally wrong to me i was trying
to give a little leash in this answer
i was thinking about it for a second i
usually just glance at the questions
real quick and i was trying to
give a little bit of a leash of like all
right if you you know because i want to
respect
the the business person's ability to run
the business as he or she she's
sees fit but something something ain't
right about this so
first i don't really think it's your
business i don't think it's anyone's
business
whether or not you've had the vaccine i
think if you want
to get the vaccine you should get the
vaccine if you want
to wear a mask you should get you should
wear the mask and take whatever other
precautions there are
but this idea that suddenly we're not
going to hire people based on their
vaccination status
or that we're going to have vaccine
passports or some people will have
separate but equal sitting areas
in in stadiums and all sorts of stuff
this is really really just dangerous
stuff
it seems by and large at this point as i
talked to you in the
in early to mid june of 2021 that a year
and a half
after two weeks to flatten the curve
covid has run through the system
whatever it needed to do politically and
socially and culturally it did
we're sort of more banged up and maybe
unsure of ourselves as a
as a human race and as a nation and as a
world because of it
but it does seem like it's mostly behind
us now there's going to be a certain set
of people who will want to use it
continually as a crudgeal over everybody
else but i think you have to make
choices for yourself and your family i i
know that's a little messy and i know
people get angry over me
angry at me over that you know that oh
you're not looking out for your common
man
um but i think your responsibility is to
yourself first and everyone should do
whatever they think is best for
themselves
and i and really i'll just end with this
i think if that's how we had treated
this thing from the beginning
that right at the beginning we had all
said if you want to wear a mask
wear a mask you know businesses can say
to people we want you to wear masks when
when you're in here we're not going to
lock everything down
you know hopefully we'll have a vaccine
soon enough if we had left far more
to human choice rather than giant
government organizations who destroyed
the economy in america and destroyed so
much of the fabric of america
i think we'd be far better off so that's
all i think about that
uh jill says have you reached out to
donald j trump
to try to convince him to start a local
community
um let's take the next
question matt says uh the answer to that
is look
we're we've built something really great
with locals i'm super proud of it as you
guys know we got some great investment
from some true innovators and and we're
working on
so many cool things we're gonna have
live video streaming we just tested it
out for the first time
uh this week in the reuben report
community where i'll just be able to
talk directly to my locals people
they'll be able to comment live
like basically we're doing you know what
is youtube super chat where youtube
takes like 60
of the money or something uh it'll all
be free within the
within the local subscription we're
figuring out a few other things within
that
um but we're just we're working on
decentralized storage and decentralized
payments
and we're on boarding more people and
there's a lot of good things going on so
if i was a guy like donald trump i would
be interested in such a thing
just saying matt says thoughts on a red
wave in the 2022 midterm elections
are we witnessing that in the new york
mayoral race
the most moderate democrat candidates
are polling the highest
so i haven't paid a tremendous amount of
attention to the new york
mayoral race as i said i grew up in long
island but most of my
adult life i lived in new york city i
lived on the upper east
for a couple years during 9 11.
right around those years late 90s early
2000s and then i lived on the upper west
basically if you've ever watched an
episode of seinfeld my entire life
took place exactly where that show took
place and jerry seinfeld actually in
real life
lived like a block away from me but all
the the outdoor
you know when they'd show you like the
restaurant canopies and all the stores
and all that stuff it was
that was the three blocks that that i
lived in um
and i love new york city i haven't paid
much attention to it because in many
ways i think new york city is lost
the progressives have destroyed new york
city and i'm not even going to say the
progressives bill de blasio is a
communist
marxist [ __ ] who has ruined the
greatest city on earth and you got to
give credit where credit's due it's not
easy
to ruin something so spectacular but
bill de blasio
has done it when i was in new york city
a couple weeks ago it it did not feel
like new york city it felt like
a halfway through i am legend i really
was looking for a tiger and will smith
running around
trying to shoot him and some zombies
chasing him like it was just an absolute
disaster
i hope new york city can come back but
the the woke virus has infected
the bluest cities and because of the
proximity of new york city
where you know a place like la you know
one of the saving graces of l.a that can
at least keep me here a little bit
longer
as we're trying to figure some things
out is that los angeles is a sprawling
sprawling city new york city is built on
top of itself in essence you know you've
got manhattan and you've got brooklyn
and the bronx
and queens etc etc but it's huge
buildings all on top of each other
that lifestyle doesn't seem like it's
really going to work in the future
anymore
so anyway as for a red wave in 2022 i
i i i don't pray over politics but i
would pray that that
is what would happen uh because we must
get
these democrats and these socialists out
of office if america
is to continue so that's number one as
far as new york look will the new
yorkers make the right choice i mean i
know that there's uh
uh eric adams is the retired police
officer who's running he's leading right
now at about 22
there's a lot of candidates i think yang
is around 16
you know those are sort of somewhat
moderate dems but we know what happens
with moderate dems they always get
pulled to their worst parts i mean look
at the democratic party right now look
at joe biden
he was supposed to be the moderate but
he's been pulled further to the left
so i don't know is there any real hope
the hope would be that at some point you
hit
such rock bottom that then you bring in
conservatives
it's such an odd thing for me to have to
argue at this point but that's exactly
what happened to new york city i
remember going there my
my grandma lived in new york city when i
was a kid i had great grandparents that
lived in new york city i remember going
as a kid and thinking who would ever
want to live here it's such a disgusting
dirty smelly gross place you know you'd
drive through the midtown tunnel coming
from long island and there'd be homeless
people washing your windows with dirty
newspapers and it was just
kind of gross and that was under at the
time that was sort of at the end
of ed koch who actually was a decent
democrat and then we had a couple years
of mayor
dinkins who david dinkins who was a
progressive basically destroyed new york
city and then you know what happened
that
scary right-wing conservative rudy
giuliani came in
and suddenly the homeless problem was
solved and businesses were flourishing
and times square
went from being a den of prostitution
and drugs
to a den of disney which is another type
of prostitution and drugs but it's a
little bit cleaner
so uh you know we need conservatives to
fix these things because democrats ain't
gonna do it so i don't have
i would say i'm long on new york as a
city uh i would play the long game on it
but short term i think they're in a lot
of trouble
uh leon says what are your top three
favorite movies that you enjoy watching
through the years
total recall by far schwarzenegger at
his best it's a philip k
dick story i absolutely freaking love
that movie i could watch it over
and over and over and over and over
again uh and you know i'll pick two
movies that we watched as part of the
the reuben report locals community we
did we've done a couple movie nights
where we watch movies together
and we can chat throughout and then we
do a video chat after uh i would say
contact
uh with jody foster and matthew
mcconaughey came out in 97
written by carl sagan uh who of course
was
was the great astrophysicist and science
communicator it's his only work of
fiction i've talked about it a couple of
times
if you haven't seen it it's just a
wonder it's a sci-fi movie but based in
reality and it talks about
it's very relevant to what's happening
right now like sort of religion versus
atheism and secularism
and political motivations and it's just
it's just a spectacularly
wonderful movie and then the other one
that everyone should watch again
because it's so uh it's so explanatory
of what's happening right now
is v for vendetta which is just such a
freaking great movie
natalie portman's in it it's the it's
the guys or i guess they're girls now
but it's the
the guy girls that did uh the matrix uh
they were
the wachowski brothers and i guess
they're the wachowski sisters now or
whatever whatever it's all good
whatever whatever works for you gals um
but they did v for vendetta and it's
just a great movie
which has a little something to do with
a virus that spreads through a society
and then as the virus starts spreading
politicians start using more and more
power and next thing you know they're
watching everything their citizens do
hmm interesting jamie says hey
dave i hear you red-pilled your
brother-in-law recently
can you give me some of the steps that i
can follow to do the same for my friends
i mean i get so many versions
of this question i've been working on
you know my brother-in-law who's just
he's just a great decent apolitical guy
he doesn't care about politics he's just
a decent human being
and i've been working on him for a long
time and the steps
well in this case i sort of finished it
off after years because we were in the
hot tub and we had some tequila and i
find if you want to red pill somebody a
little tequila
is going to go a long way but basically
the basics of it were he's a he's a
small
business owner and i we got into a lot
of stuff related to taxes
and regulation and his ability to grow
his business and he started
seeing he had to see it for himself i
mean that's i guess the answer you
the best way to red pill people is to
let them see the truth for themselves
he started seeing that it was the
policies of the democrats that were
taxing him more it was that which were
then stopping him from being able to
grow his business
appropriately so i think the real answer
is if you can get somebody to see
something that
really affects them wait a minute you
want to own a business well wouldn't you
want as much of the money of that
business so you could grow that business
and hire more people and buy more
inventory
and do more things whatever it might be
or
do you think that if you just give
enough money away to some machine above
you that that machine will be good to
you
it had a few other underlying things to
that you know he
he didn't fully realize i think until
recently that the republicans have moved
on the
on the gay marriage thing um and there
were a few other things like that
um it's just get them to see something
for themselves and if you can get them
once you can get them to see you know
the thing about the truth is that if
the truth is there the truth is in front
of us right and you just got to get
somebody to be able to
see it and once they can see a little
glimmer of it they'll go to it
themselves so
that's the best way to do it i think
peter says comments on italy's proposed
bill to ban communism good or bad
idea i just did a quick google on this
look as a general rule would i want
governments to be banning a set of ideas
probably not right like i wouldn't want
them to ban
an idea that just because i didn't like
it and then of course who watches the
watchers
you know who is the one to say what
ideas they can ban and what can't they
ban
i would liken this in an american
context what's going on with critical
race theory
i don't want the government to ban
discussion
about critical race theory you should be
able to talk about however you want
but i don't have a major problem with
the government
with state governments which is what's
happening right now in large part to my
friend chris ruffo who's doing an
incredible job
going into these states and saying we
are going to ban the idea
of of teaching critical race theory in
schools the same way you wouldn't want
them to learn about nazi
you can learn about what the nazis did
but you wouldn't want to be promoting
the ideas of nazism in school i think
most people
would agree although actually nazism and
critical race they were kind of similar
to each other in that they're
race essentialists and that we are going
to peg people by their race
um so i think you have to be careful
here because you know okay you could say
we're going to ban communism
well what other ideas are you going to
ban around that so i would need to know
a little bit more are they banning it in
schools are they banning like
all discussion of it are they going to
ban it on television things of that
nature you got to
you got to watch out for the for the
slippery slope um
but all of that said and this is maybe
why i'm not a pure libertarian
countries have to defend themselves i
think one of the
weaknesses of america right now is where
are all the good people who are really
willing to stand up
for america that's why that video of
seeing all those people proudly singing
the national anthem is so
magical and mystical because it's like
where is that
feeling where is that feeling of of
rocky balboa going
to moscow on christmas day to fight
ivan drago like where is that spirit
like we need that spirit back
and and part of that spirit is knowing
what you stand for and what you stand
against
and communism and marxism and woke-ism
these are collectivist ideas that are
against
the very idea of freedom and individual
rights
james says any post-covet lockdown
vacation plans this summer
well you know we do the august off the
grid situation we haven't had a moment
to figure it out yet um we're trying to
you know usually we go away for a little
bit like a week at least last year
because of covid and everything else
we actually moved even though we just
moved in la it was you know a move is a
lot it's just like a lot of stuff
so we didn't go anywhere you know for me
even though there's a lot of places i
would love
to go i really i would love to go to
greece i would love i really want to go
to japan
probably more than anything else i'd
love to go back to australia
there's there's a bunch of places that i
would love to go to but when
when i do the off-the-grid thing like
for me like i the purpose of it is to
put down all of the craziness and and
let my head just kind of reset
and and you know give me a little space
to think and i think that's
partly why i haven't gone crazy over the
last couple years a lot of people that
do
something like this for a living really
lost their minds a lot of people
you know trump caused people to go crazy
and and people just
really flip their wigs and i think you
know for me like sitting on a beach if
when i sit on a beach
i don't even need to read sometimes like
i try to use august to catch up on
reading but i could do like four days on
a beach
i could do probably 10 days on a beach
and i could just sit there all day david
will be next to me and he's reading or
doing crosswords or something and he's
like you're just going to sit there and
stare at the ocean and i'm like
yes that is exactly what i'm going to do
so i'm not sure yet but we'll we'll let
you guys know
jay says as a gay man well thus i must
speak for all gay people
how do you push back against reverting
to the outrageous stereotypes being
pushed on society and specifically
children
i'm actually embarrassed to call myself
gay not because i'm insecure or anything
like that
but because people now equate being gay
as being for drag
queen story hour and believing that men
can be women and so on are we going
backwards this is a great question
and i talked a little bit about this
with my guest this week
arielle scarcella who's a card-carrying
lesbian i always say card-carrying
lesbians i feel like when you're a
lesbian they give you a card they
laminate it you're a lesbian you get a
card
um i think this is a great point you
know look i happen to be gay i don't
think it's actually that interesting
david and i have been together for 10
years which in straight years is like 40
years already we've been married for
uh it'll be this year it'll be six years
um
we live a very normal life i think other
than we happen to be
two dudes i know some people aren't
thrilled with that some people really
like it some
people like to pretend that they like it
some people want to use it as power over
us
but we just we just kind of live our
lives and i think that's really the
heart of what you're getting to too
i was never really into the gay culture
i was never really into like i can't
really dance
i danced like bill cosby which could be
kind of funny maybe 10 years ago but
then he came out as the
biggest serial rapist of all time and
then if you're dancing like bill cosby
people think something else
so that's no good um i was never into
drag shows i actually always hated drag
shows because you know i came from
stand-up comedy and drag queens
all uh beyond like i found like as
godzilla would say like an aesthetic
injury with most drag queens like i
don't need to see a guy dressed as a
woman who has
huge thighs in a hairy bush like singing
you know cher songs
um i just was never into that and they
all seemed like hack comedians to me
um so i was never you know but that
being said i i
once i came out i did enjoy for five or
six years going to gay pride
actually my birthday which is june 26
gay pride in new york city always falls
on the last sunday of june so
every couple years it would be on my
birthday and actually david and i met
on my birthday at gay pride in new york
city and he was wearing an american flag
tank top so i suppose it was meant to be
um but yes i could see why a lot of gay
people right now and by the way i do
hear a lot of this so i totally hear you
on this question
are really upset because most gay people
just wanted equality and go about live
their lives
right and not make this about drag queen
story hour or boys or girls or girls or
boys or
all this other nonsense and we just
wanted to be left alone like that's the
beauty of equality once you get equality
then you can just be left alone
but the gay rights thing glaad and the
hrc
and all of their corporate backers they
they don't want to give it up because
they want their minorities oppressed i
mean this is a obvious parallel to
what's going on with black people right
now
they need them to view themselves as
oppressed but i could see
i i i have no doubt that i'm going to
get [ __ ] for this
i could see the average person who is
not a homophobe and doesn't care
about gay people watching drag queen
story hour watching the
propaganda that they put uh you know to
push kids into transitioning and the
rest of it
and then starting to become slightly
anti-gay
not because they have anything against
gay people but they think that the
movement somehow represents more than
the gay individuals and that's a huge
problem so i don't know i guess we just
need more like decent gay people
to to stand up against it um are we
going backwards though was your question
and i would say in some way yes when you
once you've got equality well then the
activists have to put down the mantle
you're allowed to say
guys we gotta win we're good thank you
everybody
we're gonna go find something else
productive to do in life but activists
always have to have smaller and smaller
problems
once you get to equality and that's the
difference between equality
and equity storm says how bad of an
action does the biden administration
have to do
before corporate media starts pressing
them i would say there's almost nothing
there's almost nothing that biden could
do
that the corporate media would turn on
him pretty much because he's
good in their eyes and trump and the
republicans are evil and and it really
sucks to end up seeing the world
that way and i think it's part of the
red pill situation
but there's nothing that you know
there's just nothing trump
when trump was president no matter what
trump did every day he had he had ice
cream he
ate ketchup with steak blah blah biden's
son
is a crack addict and by the way i'm
sympathetic to someone with a drug
addiction
but you know he's saying the n word in
texts and nobody's covering it
again i don't care about specific
language i don't even think that
necessarily makes him racist
or anything else but the media is
protecting him it's a it's a protection
racket it's like a mafia style
protection racket
between corporate media and the
democrats and and that was trump's
greatest insight perhaps into the world
was you have to fight both those things
at once
and it's kind of sucky if you're on the
outside but don't think mainstream media
is going to come around
like stelter and acosta and blitzer
and tapper these all sound they all
sound like reindeer
um like these guys aren't coming around
nbc news is not coming around the new
york times
has been rotted from the inside it's not
coming around
like once you know that then you can
plot a course going forward
uh curtis says dave since you and david
are into food have you considered giving
a tour of your kitchen so we can see
your appliances and food related gear
seeing your outdoor grill and setup
would be great too uh i have posted a
little bit more of that in the locals
community so you might have seen you
know i do a little more like the
personal stuff in there obviously um
well i'll tell you this david is working
on a cookbook um
and so we've been testing a lot of
recipes and i'm super psyched for this
to come out because that's really
what his passion is and it's what got me
really into food and grilling and
all of that stuff um we have a great new
sponsor i think starting with us next
week that just sent us like a ton
ton of meat so i'll be doing more of
that uh you can go
to davidscookbook.com and see a bunch of
david's recipes now some of them will be
included in the cookbook
and you can just see some of the great
stuff and it's also um
it's instagram.com david's cookbook if
you want to see more
of that kind of stuff and yeah we're
gonna we're gonna do more where we'll
show me grilling
i like showing people like what kind of
wine i'm drinking when i'm when i'm
doing
the the grilling and all that kind of
stuff and
yeah that's well that's honestly why i
love the reuben report community so much
because
i think we're doing something really
nice related to
connecting with people and making social
media social again you know someone in
the community the other day
i'm not even going to mention the
username it doesn't matter but said that
they were struggling financially they
had a couple things going on and they
were in between jobs and they were
waiting to get paid
for something and i immediately i i
venmed them some money and then i posted
it in the community and they were taken
care of
and it's great it's like we're really
building something great there so i know
if you've submitted a question here
you're in the community already but if
you're watching this
and you haven't it's like there's a
whole other internet
existing that has nothing to do with all
of the bots and the trolls and the evil
uh and please do join us at
reubenreport.locals.com cheryl says
uh still super curious about how you and
david navigated the political
metamorphosis
did he change on the same timeline as
you did rio at odds at any point you
know it's funny so david's a couple
years younger than me
and when we lived in new york city when
i was absolutely a lefty this was even
before i was on the young turks because
i didn't
join the young turks until 2013 we moved
to la
so i was still a lefty had a show on
siriusxm
and david and i would be talking about
stuff and i would always say to him i'd
be like you know you're
you're a republican i think you're a
republican it was like a running joke
with me
you're a little conservative aren't you
because he had never had a credit card
when he was growing up his dad didn't
believe in just racking up debt and that
sort of thing so david never had a
credit card
and he couldn't believe i remember we
were going to buy a tv like a flat
screen tv was going to be like a
thousand bucks we didn't have a lot of
cash
and i was going to put it on a credit
card and like you know pay over months
and he could not believe that you could
do that sort of thing like why would you
spend money you don't have what you
should do
is i remember exactly where we were we
were on columbus in about 82nd
walking down on the left side of the
street
and he was like well wait a minute why
would you spend money on
you know if you don't have that money
you save it up and then you get the tv
and i was like oh and then we'd start
talking about taxes because finally he
had his first job in new york city he
was getting paid a little bit more
suddenly starting to see what's going on
there
so we did sort of evolve in the same way
i would also say you know he's not
he's just a good human being he's not
hyper political i think he's you know
been sort of sucked into the political
world
because i'm in the political world so
when we have a lot of dinners there's
usually a lot of
political people and people that you
know and politicians and all that and i
think he really enjoys it and he but he
enjoys like
you know we host the dinners so to get
to the earlier question like he loves
cooking for these people
talking about that kind of stuff um and
we've just
we've just kind of been on the adventure
together and you know you see i say this
a lot you know
when you see people that are supposed to
be married and then you see people that
aren't supposed to be married and when
you see people that are supposed to be
married it's like it's kind of easy it's
just kind of
moving along and there's like a certain
mutual respect and like
like i get a kick out of you a little
frank sinatra right i always play that
song
uh and i'm always like i got a kick out
of you like that's why we're doing this
this thing here that's why we're trying
to build a life in a family together
and then you see some couples that it's
like they're just like constantly trying
to undermine and destroy each other
and it's like guys like you know
maybe there's some other options here uh
janelle says what do you think the
chances are that a lawsuit is brought
against the nih who cdc big tech
uh health and homeland security uh for
wrongful deaths violations
uh of the hippocratic oath etcetera yeah
you know i've been saying for a while
probably about a year that i think one
of the things that we're going to see
over the next couple years is a lot of
lawsuits
like i think you're going to see people
rightfully suing gavin newsom
suing gretchen whitmer in michigan suing
uh andrew cuomo in new york like these
people who did not follow science who we
know that the lockdowns had nothing to
do
with stopping cobit who destroyed lives
they they broke
people they broke people that's one of
the things that i'm usually thinking
when i'm when i'm out and about here in
l.a and today is what the today's the
10th
is that right today is june 10th so
we're still technically not fully open
for five days and so when i go to the
the supermarket still they make you put
a mask on and i usually i say to the
girl
do we really have to do it and she's
like i don't want to do it but we have
to do it and i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna get in there and fight
with somebody right um
but you see all these people still
wearing masks and i see people still
with masks walking the dog and the rest
of it and by the way it's changing a
little bit now
um but when you see it you think man
they broke
people they broke people psychologically
and you can't blame
all of the people so sometimes i'm kind
of i'll see like a group of young people
with masks outdoors i'm kind of angry at
them and then i'm like i gotta step back
for a sec like
we shouldn't be angry at them we should
be the angry at the people who did this
so i think when we find out all sorts of
things you know more information on
cuomo sending elderly sick people back
into nursing homes
when we find out lockdowns didn't do
anything when we find out you said
violation of hippocratic oath that
doctors
didn't perform certain surgeries like
like all sorts of stuff it would suck to
be in a endless um
[Music]
an endless box basically of lawsuits but
i think we
some lawsuits are probably necessary
here like fauci probably has to well he
just needs to retire just retire
dave says given the state of affairs of
today what does america look like when
you
and uh when you're and david's kids
graduate from high school
man i uh i have no idea actually i will
give a little personal update on that
that i
haven't mentioned yet so as you know a
few months ago our surrogate had a
miscarriage
um she actually had a second miscarriage
uh
just about two weeks ago which obviously
is
you know just sucks beyond belief and
unfortunately we can't use her as a
surrogate anymore so
we're on the hunt again on that front
we've got we've got embryos we've got
eggs we're good on that front
um you know there's been a lot i've
heard a lot of people having
miscarriages in this past year and
uh you know is what it would have
whacked out uh year it's been but so we
we are on that
that path and and it will happen and uh
you know it's my 45th birthday
at the end of the month and i got this
torn acl and i got something going on my
shoulder and now i got a freaking
uh this is like my retirement show
um i've got this toothache you know i
want to be able to play catch with this
kid so
we're trying to do it as quickly as
possible but your question about what do
you think america will look like when
the kids graduate high school i mean
look that could be let's say
you know 18 years from now so we're
rolling into almost 20 40.
i don't know i hope that america has
stood up for itself and fought for
itself i think the world will look
extraordinarily different
will america still be the superpower
will america be the superpower in two
years are we even the superpower now i
don't know
uh will we be sending people off world
probably
um you know what will the confluence of
the internet and reality as they
continue to crash into each other
you know are basically we just the
batteries in the matrix like there's so
many things it's unimaginable
uh but i will say there's no way in high
hell that we're sending our children to
public school uh because i don't want
them brainwashed and i know
that crt is affecting a lot of uh
private schools a lot of friends here in
l.a
who you know are wealthy and well to do
and care about their kids education and
they're seeing it now hit the private
schools as well
um so we've got we've got work to do uh
nathan says hi dave have you thought
about making plans for a speaking event
or meetup in my great peach state
of georgia i would love to get to
georgia i've only been to
uh georgia a couple times and really
just atlanta i was on tour with jordan
peterson there i've done a couple
speaking gigs
in the atlanta area actually one of the
one of the truly best nights
of the tour with jordan uh was in
atlanta we were
at um i don't know what theater was
could you maybe google it real quick
jordan peterson atlanta theater
it was a really old-school southern
theater it was really cool and what i
remember about it was
you know some theaters are really sort
of deep that way some theaters you're
going to see more people this way some
theaters are very high
this was somewhat of a shallow theater
with uh
and it was kind of high and it felt like
we were just like in this box it was
very intense yes the tabernacle atlanta
and it was just like
old school can you see what year it was
built maybe it was just an awesome
awesome theater
and it was jordan's birthday that night
and we got the entire
audience i brought out a well we didn't
want to bring out a cake
because he was on the meat diet so we
brought out a raw steak put a candle in
it and we had
about i don't know 3000 people sing him
happy birthday it was an awesome night
it was built in 1911.
great theater all right last question
here we go
give me a little roll there michael kate
i'm a golden girl's disciple and
recently had the pleasure of watching
the series again
what are some of your favorite episodes
or moments between the ladies
you're keeping it light for me thank you
i appreciate that you know you guys know
i love the golden girls it was one of my
sort of formative
comedy things i remember 1985 you know
how old am i nine or something watching
it till i remember the night it went off
the air in 1992 i was so sad dorothy
marries
blanche's uncle lucas played by leslie
nielsen from naked gun who was like my
favorite comic actor so i was happy
about that but
i was so sad it went off there and then
it had a year on cbs after being on nbc
where it was golden palace
where the other three gals ran a hotel
and my god
it was horrible like absolutely horrible
i actually
once went at usc right when i moved to
la uh i went to a thing where the
creators of the golden girls
were there they were talking about the
golden girls and betty white was there
was pretty cool
and uh what's his name uh danny thomas's
son who was one of the original
directors i can't think of his name tony
thomas yeah tony thomas
uh someone asked him about golden palace
and he goes uh that fakakta show
it was just an absolute nightmare but
the golden girls was just great they
dealt with social issues they
it was just funny you know to hear older
women talking about sex
and the actresses were all spectacular
it was it was
just it's just a perfect perfect show it
still stands up you know a lot of these
shows don't stand the test of time
it still does i'll give you one one
scene that i think
really encapsulates why the show was so
great there was a
uh two-part uh well it wasn't a two-part
episode but there were two episodes
dealing with blanche's brother
clayton and clayton comes out as gay and
in the first episode where he comes out
first off you meet this guy clayton
and he just seemed like a normal guy
that he wasn't a flamboyant whatever and
not that there's anything wrong with
that
but that's a little seinfeld reference
for you but he i remember watching it
thinking oh he was just this normal guy
and he had been married to a woman and
then he came out and he was later in
life
he comes out and they they really deal
with it in a mature way and then about a
season later
he comes back and now he's getting
married to doug
and doug is a cop you would have no idea
he's gay so you have these two sort of
very normal
and when i say normal i don't mean that
normal is so spectacular but just like
regular people
regular decent human beings clayton and
doug the cop
and they're getting married now first
off this is 1991 i think
nbc 8 o'clock prime time and they're
talking about gay marriage even though
it wasn't for another almost 30 years
that gay marriage got legalized
especially in florida
florida didn't do it by the states as
some of them did obviously florida was
because of the supreme
court decision but they they go through
the whole episode
they have this interesting debate about
gay marriage
and all of this stuff and i don't this
was early on in my life i don't even
know that i was thinking about any stuff
but i'll give you the line that to me
just
just so captures why the show was so
great uh
cl blanche is talking to clayton about
doug and she's like i don't understand
why you want to marry this guy like
can't you be gay but not marry this guy
and clayton and he's got a southern
accent the southern drawl he looks at
her he says
you know i'd do anything for doug and
doug would bend over backwards for me
that is a gay sex joke that was played
on nbc prime time 1991
8 o'clock one of the biggest shows in
the country
and it was it was a joke first off it's
funny like that's just funny
but it was also saying something about
life and reality and people
and all of those things so that's what a
truly good show can do right it can make
you laugh
and it can hopefully do something that's
relevant culturally and socially
and all that stuff so that's that's just
one of my favorite episodes i'll give
you a couple of their favorite episodes
real quick
uh case of the libertine bell which i
believe is uh uh
season seven maybe episode two where
they go to the murder mystery thing
is an absolute classic and uh and i'll
give you the most underrated episode
ever
it's i also season seven maybe episode
seven or so
when blanche meets this guy who was a
soldier
in the iraq war desert storm and she
can't remember him and he comes back
the opening of that episode the first
five minutes it's it's comedy perfection
all right i think i've lost some of you
but i kept another special
set of you so there you go um part two
of my interview with arielle scarcella
the card carrying lesbian who left the
left is up on youtube right now the full
episode is up early and ad free at
rubinreport.locals.com and tomorrow
we've got a really interesting panel so
we're gonna do another recap
of the the news of the week in essence
dr simone gold she is the doctor who we
played the video of yesterday who over
the summer was screaming
about uh hqc and was screaming about how
we can solve
the covid without lockdowns and
everything else we've got her on
uh david harris jr i've been on his show
a couple times real
uh real fighter for his beliefs and stu
bergery from blaze who's a good guy who
have been on his show many times
we will all be doing that at 11 o'clock
tomorrow unless i go to the
dentist right now and they literally
just remove my face in which case we
probably won't do a show tomorrow anyway
i think i'm off to get
root canal ah is my face blown up it
feels like my face is like blown up
you no not blown up all right anyway
have a great day everybody
enjoy yourselves be proud of america
and who you are let's fix this thing i'm
in it you're in it
that's all see ya god bless america
love you